[Music]
[Applause]
whenever a shipment of biontech fisa
coronavirus vaccine arrives in south
africa
it makes the headlines
because the country's vaccination
programme has been struggling
it got off to a late start first using
astrazeneca's jab
but that was stopped over its
ineffectiveness
against the variant spreading rapidly in
the country
then south africa turned to johnson
johnson's vaccine
but pause that roll out due to concerns
about
side effects but with a second wave of
infections
now behind them life is starting to
appear normal in south africa
but it may not stay that way
[Music]
welcome to this covered 19 special i'm
rob watts in berlin
the coronavirus situation in south
africa has relaxed in recent weeks
the country has now put one of the
world's harshest
lockdowns and two worrying waves
of new cases behind it the number of new
daily infections is around 2000 a day
just a tenth of what it was in late
january the second peak you can see
there
but the improvement is despite a slow
start in south africa's vaccination
campaign
and its battle with a mutated virus
variant
adrian creesh reports
camps bay in cape town concern about the
pandemic seems far away here in the last
days of summer
many people are still socially
distancing but the mask mandate is
rarely followed
to be honest i'm just enjoying the beach
today i missed out a lot
a lot i feel like the weekends are just
two minutes these days
i miss going out i am happy that i'm
free i'm able to come to the beach and
have fun with friends
for quite some time we've missed the
beach you see we've been deprived even
in the art of summer
december we had a like all of a sudden
locked down
people couldn't come to the beach we
were away from the fresh
air enjoying the sea you know
seeing the sun set but this is life
we're very happy that our life is coming
back to normal the economy has been open
unlike in europe where many of those
countries have gone into higher levels
of just fiction
as the epidemic gains momentum in south
africa even during the course of the
first wave
we went in opposite direction in that we
started off with very high levels of
restriction
and then as the epidemic was gaining
momentum and we weren't able to sustain
high levels of restriction we became
more lenient
and went to lower levels of restriction
and inadvertently what that resulted in
was a high percentage of the population
getting infected
antibodies studies show that almost half
of the population of cape town has
already been infected
in densely populated townships the rate
is even higher
the excess death rate suggests that more
than 150 000 people have died of
coronavirus during the pandemic
virologist wolfgang kreiser worries that
the mutation could be more resistant
against vaccines
as well as the antibodies people develop
after early infections
similar to the brazilian mutation but
this hasn't been verified
by studies there's still no proof of a
higher death rate among the new
mutations
and there are glimmers of hope districts
within cape town
that were badly affected during the
first wave seemed to be less badly
affected during the second wave
and that makes one think of a somehow
protective effect there's some some
likely evidence
of some protective effect even
after infection with the previous wild
virus
now against the variant but what we
think is that if you've had
infection with a new variant virus you
will be immune
also against any preceding ones and that
is the good news
and his team are already preparing for
the third wave and they're increasing
testing capacities
since so many rules aren't being adhered
to the number of new infections could
start rising again
well we can now speak to cheryl cohen
who is the co-head of the center for
respiratory disease at south africa's
national institute for communicable
diseases thank you very much for joining
us on the covered 19 special how would
you characterize the coronavirus
situation in south africa is there a
feeling that
it's over the worst so so thanks for
having me i think um
you know right now in south africa case
numbers are
at a relatively low level um and they
have been
reducing since since the peak of our
second wave
around the the new year but but i
certainly you know wouldn't characterize
it as the
as the um risk is over um we know from
from previous waves that
um you know case numbers reach very high
levels and then they came down
but there certainly remains a risk that
case numbers may
increase again so so right now um you
know except in a small number of
provinces
um case numbers are generally at a low
level um but
that doesn't mean at all that they'd be
complacent or think that they
necessarily will remain at this level
yeah are you working on the assumption
that there will be
a third wave or are you uh i i suppose
hoping that it can just be avoided
well so i think um you know if we if we
look at or think about the possibility
of a third wave um we we know um that we
have
experienced two large waves in south
africa but there have been a number of
studies um looking at
population immunity or proportion of
people that have been infected in a
country and and while
you know in some areas of the country
immunity levels appear to be
fairly high even as high as 60 percent i
mean in areas of the western cape where
where we know there's been intense
transmission you know other areas have
much lower
levels of people that have been infected
sitting around 30
30 so so so based on that i mean
it would appear to be likely that that
there will be a third wave
um and and you know
also taking into account the fact that
restrictions have relaxed um
substantially since the peak of the wave
mostly around
trying to get the economy going and
generate economic
activity so i think most experts would
agree that it is likely that there will
be another wave in south africa um
i suppose the difficulty is perhaps to
to predict the timing and the the
magnitude of that wave
one of the things i suppose you're
hoping to do is head that wave off with
vaccinations but the the vaccination
program
isn't going as well as you might have
hoped so i think vaccination
got off to a slower start than was hoped
um
largely related to concerns about about
the the new variant which which did
emerge in south africa really
around the time of that rolling out of
the vaccination program so
so up until now about 350 000 healthcare
workers have
been vaccinated through through a
program um
[Music]
really focusing on healthcare workers
out of about one to 1.5 million
potentially eligible
healthcare workers but i think south
africa is planning over the next few
weeks in fact to move into a much more
upscaled intensive vaccination program
the plan
a number several million doses are
expected to arrive in the country over
the next
few months um the the the target group
is expanding
within the next three weeks to include
individuals over the age of 60
with a plan to to really decrease that
age ban quite rapidly
over the the subsequent months um so so
there is a plan certainly to to
upscale vaccination uh rapidly and the
eventual target is really to get to
about two-thirds of the population
vaccinated towards the end of this year
into
into next year but but you know
restrictions on for example the use of
the astrazeneca
vaccine and also there was a pause of
the johnson johnson
vaccine has south africa tied its own
hands
by making these restrictions
well i think i i think the two issues
are different i think the johnson and
johnson was a pause
with regard to to safety concerns and i
think that you know that's quite a
normal thing
many other countries in europe and other
parts of the world also
instituted a pause um in response to the
safety concerns until we we
we we got information that that
confirmed that that the vaccine
was safe yes that may have had negative
impact on on
acceptance of the vaccine um but but uh
you know i think that again may have
been experienced in
in other parts of the world um with
regard to to the astrozenica
vaccine i think it was a complex
decision um
and um you know i think it yeah
but i wouldn't say we've tied our hands
i think now the government has really
secured um uh
you know supply of a number of other
vaccine products which are supposed
coming into the country
over the next few weeks
well thank you very much for taking the
time to speak to us cheryl cohen from
south africa's national institute
for communicable diseases
now it's time to answer more of your
questions over to our science
correspondent derek williams
is there any conclusive evidence for
avoiding alcohol before
or after receiving a covid19 vaccine
asking for conclusive evidence for
anything in this pandemic is setting the
bar
pretty high which is why most of the
commentary
that i read on this topic has has been
pretty hedged and
and i couldn't find any really clear
directives issued by
trustworthy healthcare bodies like the
cdc or the who
saying you should stop drinking
completely before or between
vaccine shots maybe it's best therefore
to start by looking at the conclusive
evidence that we do
have we know alcohol abuse
is bad for your health pretty much
everyone agrees on that
and and there are convincing studies out
there showing that one of the things
regular heavy alcohol consumption
impacts negatively
is immune system response there are
other studies however
showing that light or moderate drinking
doesn't have the same impact and and
even some
indicating it might actually bolster
your immune response so so most
medical professionals appear to be
adopting a kind of
middle of the road approach to this
question and saying
hey it's fine to have a celebratory beer
or a glass of champagne
after you've been vaccinated but adding
that it's never a good idea
to to over indulge particularly after
receiving a vaccination
after all aside from the potential
direct health considerations of that
having a hangover
would almost certainly make any
potential
vaccine side effects even less
pleasant to deal with
[Music]
derek williams there and before we go a
reminder that nowhere is safe
from coveted 19 not even the highest
place on earth
more than 30 climbers have just been
evacuated from the foot of mount everest
after taking ill from coronavirus as
nepal suffers a second wave of
infections
the country's tourism sector depends on
the thousands of people who come every
year
to climb the world's tallest mountain
it's now trying to recover from a total
shutdown of the himalayan summits
last year and that's all from this dw
covered 19 special for more check out
dway.com19.
take
[Music]